Unlike recessive trait pedigrees, dominant traits appear
more frequently within a pedigree, and often
do not skip generations. I'm showing you here a really great example of a
dominant trait called achondroplasia. Achondroplasia is a
major cause of dwarfism in humans. Now
in this particular pedigree, again you'll notice
right away that it effects every generation. Right?
We see every generation from grandparents to parents
to children, we see affected individuals. Now to this
point in the course, we haven't talked about
any specific genetic alleles that cause achondroplasia, but no
worry. We can go back to using our
symbols like we were using for lactose intolerance, the
plus and the minus. In this case, the
plus or the dominant allele is actually for achondroplasia
which causes dwarfism, and the minus allele is
what we're going to call quote, unquote normal. In this
case what we mean by normal is just
normal height. So take a look at this particular
grandfather in this pedigree of the dominant trait
of anchandroplasia, and I want you to tell me
what are the possible genotypes of this indicated grandfather?
This question is not as simple as it seems,
so take a nice hard look at the pedigree here and then give
it your best shot. Check any and all boxes that you think apply.